>> Keith: IT'S A TOUGH JOB.
KUDOS TO THE GUYS THAT HAD TO DO
IT.
NOT JUST THE GOALTENDERS, BUT
THE GUYS THAT SPENT MOST OF THE
SEASON ON A TAXI
NEVER HAD TO DO IT BEFORE, AND
HOPEFULLY NEVER WILL AGAIN.
>> Brendan: HERE'S PAGEAU, AND
HERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO GO HERE
IN OT.
PALMIERI WITH A SHOT, AND HE
SCORES.
KYLE PALMIERI, HAVING A DAY, AND
THE ISLANDERS TAKE GAME ONE.
>> Keith: WELL, NO SURPRISE IT'S
PALMIERI.
WHAT A GAME FOR THAT GUY, AND
THAT'S GOT TO MAKE LOU FEEL
GREAT.
THE TRADE DEADLINE ACQUISITIONS
AND THE GOAL AND HE BURIES THE
GAME WINNER IN OVERTIME WITH A
GREAT SHOT UP AND OVER THE GLOVE
HAND ON THE SHORT SIDE OF
TRISTAN JARRY.
YOU CAN SEE THE REACTION RIGHT
THERE, AND PALMIERI WAS NOT
LIGHTING IT UP AFTER HIS
ADDITION TO THE ISLANDERS
LINEUP, AND FINDS A WAY TO GET
IT DONE AT THE MOST OPPORTUNE
TIME.
BOUNCING PUCK AND HE'S STILL
ABLE TO ELEVATE IT THROUGH A
SMALL WINDOW ABOVE THE SHOULDER
OF JARRY.
BOUNCING PUCK, WHAT A SKILLFUL
PLAY BY PALMIERI, RIDES OFF THE
SHOULDER AND UP UNDERNEATH THE
BAR.
>> A.J.: LOOK AT THAT EXPRESSION
AND LOOK AT THAT EMOTION.
YOU'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT J.G.
PAGEAU TODAY AS WELL, AND HE WAS
THE ONE IN THE CORNER AND HE WAS
THE ONE THAT GOT THE PRIMARY
ASSIST ON THAT.
THAT LINE WAS VERY, VERY GOOD.
VERY NOTICEABLE.
THAT MIDDLE SIX WAS PARTICULARLY
NOTICEABLE FOR THE ISLANDERS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE GAME TODAY.
>> Brendan: KYLE PALMIERI SCORED
TWO GOALS IN 17 GAMES AFTER THE
TRADE FROM THE NEW JERSEY
DEVILS.
HE SCORES TWO GOALS IN GAME ONE